let me ask you another trippy out there
question uh so uh again perhaps
unanswerable from a physics perspective
but do you wander about
um alien civilizations do you wonder
about
other intelligent beings out there
making up their own math and physics
trying to figure out the world do you
think they're they're out there
it is hard to understand
why there would given that there's so
many planets and of course there's
Drake's formula and we don't exactly
know what the
but I mean I think fermi's Paradox that
you know
is a real Paradox and
I
I think they're
there probably are and uh I think it's
very exciting that uh
you know we might you know find some
it's it's a logical possibility that we
could learn about it I mean to me it's
super interesting to think about aliens
from a perspective of physics because so
any intelligent civilization is going to
be contending with the ideas I'm just
trying to understand the world around it
so I think that the alien I think that
the universe is filled with alien
civilizations so they all have their
physicists right they all have their
they're all trying to understand the
world around them and it's just
interesting to me to imagine all these
different perspectives all these
different Einsteins yeah like trying to
make sense of like though they might be
more different than we think well they
might be different in a way that we
haven't even thought of like smarter or
different
just just different something that we
don't even we're not even able to
describe now we just haven't thought
about it you know man
yeah this is a really frustrating thing
when we think from me as an AI person
you start to think about what is
intelligence which is consciousness you
start to sometimes again uh night
evening thoughts is um
how little we understand how narrow our
thinking is about these Concepts yeah
yeah that that it could be intelligence
could be something could be intelligent
and be very different intelligent in a
very different way they won't be able to
detect because we're not keeping an open
mind open enough mind
and that's kind of sad because to me
there's also just a strong possibility
that aliens or something like alien
intelligence or some
fascinating beautiful physical phenomena
are all around us
and we're too dumb to see it
for now
or to close-minded to see it
there's something we're just deeply
missing well there's uh like fundamental
limitations of our cognitive abilities
or just because our tools are too
primitive right now
or like the way we it's like you said
like uh
the idea seemed trivial once you figure
it all out
looking back yeah but
that kind of makes me sad because there
could be so much Beauty in the world
we're not seeing
because they're too dumb there surely is
and that's I guess the process of
Science and physics is to keep exploring
to keep exploring
to find the thing that will uh in a
century seem obvious
well something we know for sure I mean
the brain we don't
really understand and that's got to base
some
fabulously beautiful story that uh I'm
hoping some of that story will be
written through the process of trying to
build a brain so the process of
engineering intelligence
not just the neuroscience perspective of
just looking at the brain but trying to
create it
uh
but yeah that story hasn't been written
almost at all which is the early days of
figuring that one out but see like you
said that math is discovered so
um aliens should at least have the same
math as us
right I think so maybe different symbols
oh well they might have discovered
different
they might have discovered it
differently
and they might have had a different idea
of what a proof is
sure yeah we're very uh we're very like
black and white with the proof thing
yeah maybe they're looser
right well so you can you can know
something is true
to first of all you never know something
is true with 100 uncertainty I mean
you might have had a blackouted some
just to be it's never a hundred percent
right you you might have had a momentary
lapse of Consciousness it's a key step
in the proof and nobody read it and
whatever okay so you never know for sure
but you can
be have a preponderance of evidence
which makes it
and preponderance of evidence
is not accepted very much
in mathematics and and that was sort of
how you know the famous ramanujan work
he worked he had formulas which he
guessed at and then he
gathered a preponderance of evidence
that that you were sure they were true
and so there might be or something
completely different you know they might
function in a different in a very
different way